[Music]
for sure the basic ingredients involved
high intelligence a great deal of energy
management work is very demanding
it requires persistence it requires a
lot of patience it requires a kind of
courage a real intellectual honesty a
willingness in other words to see
something difficult and be have the
communication skills so that you can
help others to see and then to go on it
so that's those are very personal
characteristics what people can learn is
that to succeed they are going to have
to enlist the efforts of others that
whatever it is their job is to get great
people and help them to work well
together in an organization as teams and
that they can't succeed without great
people
I happen to be very impressed with what
Jack Welch would it was able to do it GE
to begin with he had a good record
building running the divisions that he
was given responsibility for but when he
came to GE he followed reg Jones and
Jones was on the cover of Fortune as
manager of the decade so he was taking
over an organization that was regarded
as doing very very well and Jack saw
that GE would die if it would continue
to long the path that it was going many
corporations did die in the eighties if
you remember but were dismantled and so
he shifted the portfolio of the company
he sold businesses that were very
vulnerable to competition from Asia
he entered growth businesses he just
destroyed the bureaucracy of the company
I mean they GE hat was about 400,000
when he took over it went down I think
to roughly 200,000 hard half the people
that's a huge economic benefit to the GE
assuming that they can function well
with that with half the number of people
it doubles the productivity in of it and
most of what left for staff and layers
of mineral management that got between
the leadership and the operations and
this whole notion we have today that
everybody embraces of a flat
organization is something that comes out
of that work because we saw it could be
done and then he was able to support
innovation and develop some really very
fine manager
to succeed him who in their own way are
also very different so he I mean he did
a remarkable job very different also a
very good job I mean Lou Gerstner and
then soundless Sam Palmisano at IBM have
just transformed what was you know
Gerstner inherited an IBM that was
really in crisis restored it and in a
way Palmisano had a harder job because
IBM was regarded by many as fixed if you
like and I think his part of his many
contributions involves saying that look
we're not broken anymore but there's a
lot more work to do
and they've done just a dramatic job I
mean one can go on lastly a Proctor and
Gamble that a really remarkable job and
sort of restoring that company's
confidence in its skills and getting it
focused on growing areas both in terms
of product and geography and driving it
forward
the envisioning part is hard because
sometimes it it well it often means
being critical of activity that is very
successful currently it's understanding
that things just have to change and if
you look at higher education today which
is where I live
it's inconceivable that we can keep
accepting steadily rising cost costs
rising higher than inflation higher than
a lot of the rest of society that we can
pay staff and-and-and faculty more that
we can have a tenured faculty with no
retirement age it's we're headed for a
crisis now there will be leaders of
great institutions that will see that
and they will find ways of addressing it
that's it what's it's not too hard to
see it what's hard is to see it and then
think about how it might be changed and
often that means this I mentioned
getting other extremely talented people
maybe more talented than you are who to
help you work with the problem that
you've identified the leader doesn't
have to do everything CEO doesn't have
but that for sure they have to
understand what kind of a change is
needed or that and why and then they
have to be able to assemble really good
people and get them committed to working
on the problem and then they have to
have the courage to keep going because
the early results are often difficult